seriously though oh hello welcome to the
estate of neville Gallimore we'd like to
introduce you to our next-door neighbor
Lloyd cushion Barry I'm not kidding
Lloyd cushion Barry is brakes Beck and
he is going to the Denver Broncos I want
to show you what we are doing here let's
cut the BS it is officially the
quarantine Superbowl let's get this raft
on the road because we know the Bengals
are taking Jobar oh why wait when you
look at jobber oh my number two overall
player this year but also the second
highest quarterback I have ever greeted
behind Andrew Luck coming out of
Stanford I mean come on guys a plus plus
I promise this will probably be the only
one of that night but he's that good the
Las Vegas Raiders are going
Henry rugs the third this speedster wide
receiver out of Alabama Connor I'm just
gonna say this all the left coast show
fans right now that's right a spray boys
what did you get him at 7 to 1 yeah it's
correct my friend plus 700 is where that
lovely lined open in New Jersey if you
were writing a bedtime story about
offensive lineman it would be about
Tristan worse you're telling me that
they took the small wide receiver they
had an option for a kid that had over a
hundred receptions in the SEC and tore
up defenses had caught four touchdowns
in the national championship and they
take a guy that isn't taller than Connor
Rodgers in the first round with
Jefferson on the board if you start
bawling out and all these Eagles fans
want adjusted hey you start bowing out
hey I just want to pull the cap off
Halloween and I am more than happy to
issue that that was from a little bit
earlier today our own master did it i G
live chat with Jalen Rhaegar and I'm
gonna try him on FaceTime mahomes and if
he doesn't pick up then he doesn't pick
up and if he does then like I'm top five
guys that's ever existed in the world
well you know that's what tonight's been
about Phillip Rivers is used to being
around young
kids and now he's surrounded by two more
Michael Pittman at wide receiver
Jonathan Taylor at running back it's a
whole new look offense in Indy
yeah ten tight ends and only one is good
and that's the one they just drafted
that's Cole comment' this is a b-plus
yeah I think he's gonna be an offensive
weapon left oh I'm sorry I have to give
it a question mark though I I have no
idea what you're doing with this I got
to stand about ten feet away from the
guy doing red zone reps in the Senior
Bowl and it's the one time where I take
a couple steps back because if he ran
into me he would have broke me in half I
am pretty sure that the pre-draft
process for the Raiders is they ask a
draft prospect would you punch me in the
face and if they say yes they draft up
because that's the kind of players
they're collecting right now he's just
gonna be okay because my limited amount
of Spanish told me that a CSC means okay
Browns are up right now but we do have a
common the app from P Chamberlin that
says I don't know how y'all haven't peed
yet impressive pretty good their eyes
we have Hennessy in Atlanta and we have
cushion berry I'm Denver I mean this is
perfect this is incredible
yeah they might need to make those
hallways a little wider at the Cardinals
facility with the size of this lad it's
like Chipotle you go they ask you you
want it to go you want it to stay you
get your rice chicken and get the hell
out and then I come in an order
quesadilla a mess everybody's dip yeah I
want to throw you under the bus like
that I do it don't care
Buffalo Bills get an absolute steal the
number 77 overall player on live big
board Connor Rogers I can't this guy to
Kirk Cousins maybe just maybe he has a
similar career where balls in the draft
becomes a starter and then is getting
paid mega money by a team listen it's
not often that we're wrong and in this
case we weren't